PROFESSOR: All right.
We have this, so let's complete
the Einstein discussion.
And that's practical
formulas that
are relevant to some
of the exercises
you will find in homework.
So when we set up the rates
in Einstein's argument,
we said that for
spontaneous emission,
Einstein's spontaneous emission,
he put a rate that was--
he said the number
of transitions
that occur due to
spontaneous emission
is proportional to
the number of atoms,
Nb, the number of
photons present,
times some coefficient
that I don't know, Bab.
That's how the rate of
atoms changing and going
from the top level
to the low level was.
But this is the one per atom.
This is the transition
rate per atom, multiplied
by the number of atoms present
in the top level gave you
the rate for
spontaneous emission.
This quantity is the one that
is equal to that omega ab.
So this is equal to
omega ba, like this.
Therefore, if you compare
the Bab of Einstein,
it's all except the
U. So Bab is 4 pi
squared over 3h squared
dab vector squared.
So Einstein could not
do that because he
didn't have quantum theory.
But we do, and we now can
calculate from first principles
this quantity in an
atomic transition.
And the other good thing
was that even though there
was a rate for
spontaneous emission,
that rate was fixed
by Einstein's argument
to be h bar omega ba
cubed over pi c cubed Bab.
So if you knew
the b coefficient,
you knew the a coefficient for
spontaneous emission-- many
times were interested
in spontaneous emission.
So we calculate the stimulated
emission coefficient, here,
and that's given in terms
of this matrix element.
We might as well give
the general formula.
So you just substitute
the Bab, and now we
have that A is equal to 4/3
omega ba cubed over h bar
c cubed Bab squared
4/3 omega ba cubed.
There's one h bar in the bottom.
There's the c cubed.
Yep.
So that completes that argument.
We now have combined
our development
in time dependent
perturbation theory
with a statistical
physics argument.
[INAUDIBLE] to
determine those rates.
A little more is
needed if you have
to compute a practical
rate, as you will
have to do for the homework.
It's just the concept
of a lifetime.
And a couple of selection rules.
So let me make a few
comments about it.
We get, for example,
a decay rate,
A. It's a rate for
spontaneous emission.
You have an atom.
There's a decay rate, A. So if
you have a population of atoms,
N atoms, at t equals 0, and A
being the decay rate per atom,
it means that the
number of states
that are changing in a little
time, dt, is minus A times dt--
the rate multiplied
by the time per atom--
times the number of atoms.
So dN dt is minus AN.
And the number of atoms as
a function of t go N at t
equals 0 times e
to the minus At.
So since we always
call processes
that go e to the minus t over
tau-- tau is the lifetime.
That is nothing
else than 1 over A.
So you get the decay rate.
It's synonymous to a lifetime.
You just invert it.
No big problem.
Nevertheless, if
you have an object,
sometimes can decay
in different ways.
It can decay maybe
to one type of state,
another type of state,
a third type of state.
So the total A might
be equal to A1 plus A2
when there are various
decay channels.
You can decay-- a system can
decay from an excited state.
It can go to one state to
another state to a third state.
Each one contributes
a total decay rate
because a total
disappearance of those atoms
is because they either go into
one or the other or the third.
So this is true that the
total decay rate is that.
So this gives you a relation.
The total lifetime,
which is 1 over this,
is the sum of the inverses
of the partial lifetimes.
So if you have a process
that can go in various ways,
you may want to combine them
to get a total lifetime.
So the last thing we
should say about this--
the last thing
we're going to do is
mention what happens
when you really
try to calculate these
things for hydrogen levels.
You're going to have
the ability to calculate
the lifetime of an excited
state of hydrogen now.
That's quite the thing,
to be able to get
a number that is correct up to
factors of 2 and is measurable.
So what do you have to consider?
Well, the only thing
we haven't quite done
is computed this matrix
element of the dipole operator.
You see, everything else
that could be done was done.
We integrated over the
incoherent radiation,
we found the Fermi golden rule,
we have everything simplified.
But still, the matrix
element is something
that you have to calculate.
So there's some selection rules.
Rules.
And this will be
discussed in recitation.
It's pretty important stuff.
I'll just mention the results.
It's very readable in Griffiths.
And it has to do with
the matrix elements.
So d is the dipole operator,
so it boils down to r.
So if you really knew n l
prime m prime, the matrix
elements of nlm, if you knew
all of this, you would be done.
You could calculate anything.
So the question is, when
do these elements exist,
and when are they nonzero?
You need them to be nonzero to
get a nonzero transition rate.
So when do they not vanish?
So the only cases these--
I'll summarize the answer--
are nonzero, these
can be nonzero--
there can still be accidents
and they could cancel--
only if delta m, the change
in m from one side to another,
which is m prime minus m,
is either equal to 0 or plus
or minus 1.
You cannot change that quantum
state of a system with a dipole
interaction unless m
changes at most by 1.
And moreover, the one
that is quite interesting
as well is that delta l,
which is l prime minus l,
must only be plus or minus 1.
So those changes have to happen.
So now you can at least get
a qualitative understanding
of the hydrogen atom stability.
You have the ground
state here, 1S.
Here is 2S, 2P, 3S, 3P, and 3D.
Let's see who can go to who.
Well, the ground state
cannot go anywhere.
That's at the bottom.
So OK.
2S going to 1S.
Is it possible?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Very good.
It violates delta l.
So this doesn't happen.
So if this doesn't
happen, this 2S
can almost go nowhere
because it doesn't have--
it has to go by
spontaneous emission.
Something has to go
to something lower,
so it almost
doesn't go anywhere.
So actually, it has
a long lifetime,
and it can decay via two photons
or more complicated decays.
And we will not consider it.
But this is fairly stable.
Now, this one, 2P,
can go here because it
can go from l equal
1 to l equal 0,
and it can change
m by some value.
The 3S you would say, oh, it
cannot go here, cannot go here,
but it can go laterally in that
direction because it can go
change l from 1 to 0.
So it's a change of l,
and that is possible.
The 3P can go here.
And my diagram starting
to get cluttered.
And it could go here as
well, all the way down.
And the 3D can only go here.
Cannot go up to here because
that would be l equal 2.
So that is your diagram of
possible decays of hydrogen.
And you're going to be
computing a couple of those.